the bite and white house is not happy
with Hunter's latest con the first son
reportedly wants to set up a legal
defense fund you heard that right that
would help pay for his high priced
lawyers yep that's right somewhere out
there a former crack addicted first son
is crying out for help and struggling to
pay his monthly child support operators
are standing by won't you please
consider a donation high-level Democrats
are obviously freaking out man
especially if contributions come from
foreign entities the next stop on the
hunter headache Express is the
intelligence Community email show ex-cia
Chief Mike Morrell worked overtime
recruiting his Intel buddies to sign off
on that now Infamous letter discrediting
Hunter Biden's laptop the goal of the
letter was to give Joe Biden a talking
point for the debate and of course he
used it
there are 50 former National
Intelligence folks who said that what
this he's accusing me of is a Russian
plan they have said that this is has all
the Care four five former heads of the
CIA both parties say what he's saying is
a bunch of garbage
he's a liar what did you make of some of
the communication between former CAF
Mike Morrell and another former CIA this
is the Smoking Gun that the media
desperately wanted so badly with Trump
and never got and now you have the Smoky
gum this is not smoke this is the gun
and it's like the media is like I mean
they're wearing their bias on their
sleeve this is this is they would have
taken less of this from Trump and this
is actually what matters not Hunter
sexomania this is a deep State
corruption that makes Watergate look
like a water slide you can't trust any
signed letters from intelligence again
even if it's about important stuff like
AI fentanyl or China if they had signed
a petition to bring 24 back then it
would have been okay but this is wrong
this is wrong this email is a big
Revelation and get and it wasn't the
work of investigative reporters of the
Pulitzer prize-winning journalists of
the Washington Post and those people
aren't even interested in basically that
the fact that the Deep State manipulated
the Press out in the open to change an
election a soft coup if you will how is
that not election interference it's
worse than that yeah that's that's what
I don't understand but obviously you
know you're watching this with some
excitement because you are planning on
donating to Hunter's legal defense
I maxed out that's a question I'd have
for the judge if you have a legal
defense fund can you rate it and spend
it on whatever you want because this is
better than the painting scam yeah the
painting scam was pretty Next Level you
got to give him credit especially with
the anonymous purchases but now you set
up a legal defense fund you can take
that money and do anything you want with
it he can get escorts with it he could
pay child support with it he could buy a
house in Malibu with it there's no one
to account for that kind of money so
this is just another Hunter Biden scam
that the media is going to say oh the
guy needs help where did the diamond go
he pawned it and then did what with the
cash where did the barisma money go and
Joe Biden himself is worth 8 million he
took out a line of credit on his house
for a quarter Million last month where
did that money go and we know that the
sugar brother who paid off the 2 million
in the back taxes is now hiding Hunter's
assets he took the 10 stake in the
Chinese company and he said that's mine
now so Hunter doesn't have any exposure
to it and the woman down in Arkansas
can't touch it this is good it's good
I'll give him credit it's good I'll tell
you what she touched it plenty
um so judge let's talk about some of
those ethical concerns that that Jesse
raises there have to be people within
the bite Administration who are worried
about the Optics of a legal defense fund
but you know he has been generating
money for a long long time you know what
it was during the Obama Administration
that Obama's people were worried about
the Optics of uh Hunter going with his
father where we now know we collected
1.5 billion from the Chinese for
whatever company he had at that point
but considering that this legal defense
fund it is so sanctimonious it is so
stunning that this guy who literally has
compromised just about every agency in
our in our government first of all he's
compromised the Intel agencies we just
saw them getting together uh he also
compromised an election because people
say have they known about the laptop
they might have voted differently he
compromised the Secret Service who found
a gun in a garbage can that gun that he
got with a a missile permit application
that he lied on he's compromised the doj
that's taken five years to figure out
whether or not they can indict him on
charges that I could sit here during the
next 10 minutes and do an indictment
myself okay and he's compromised the
president of the United States who has
made questionable decisions regarding
policy
from countries where he's got money this
kid is such a dirtbag he is such an
anchor he is such a deadbeat on not just
his father but on the country and and
for him to actually have a legal defense
fund is just outrageous it's stunning
and you know when you think about I said
to myself you know when they had
GoFundMe uh uh on some of the websites
for GoFundMe uh fundraisers they were
shut down for conservatives like Kyle
Rittenhouse had one that was shut down
the freedom Convoy the truckers their
GoFundMe was shut down Andy Nago the
independent journalist who was assaulted
that was shut down anti-backs GoFundMe
that was shut down this thing will go
forever and you know what no one is
going to question who's given money how
they're siphoning money whether it's
coming from a foreign country or someone
who's already maxed out to Joe because
we still don't know who gave him a half
a mil a half a million dollars for some
ridiculous second grade artwork I mean
this this guy is an infection that won't
go away
yeah unfortunately he knows that the
hard way
um but Harold there's obviously a
struggle within the White House and
there are people who are very upset by
this and there are people who are
defending the first son I know where you
would be on this because you're a smart
person you're a decent person you're
also rational which is why you should
run as Joe Biden's VP yeah the fox
audience loves you and obviously they
should flip it well they will I mean
[Music]
oh but I think Harold are you with me
Harold
it's a lot of questions there I I'll say
this you're kind oh and second this this
Hunter buying thing I I he has every
right to to launch a legal defense fund
yeah so do these five conservatives
right but judge so I'm not I'm not
saying I'd support what he's what he's
trying to raise I wouldn't give money to
the legal defense fund but people have
every right I want to give money to the
funds you raised either the other people
you raised if he does not put some guard
rails around this and I've saw one of
the former spokesman at the the justice
department saying uh earlier you're
going to have a problem if you're allow
lobbyists and foreign governments and
foreign people to give foreigners to
give it's going to obviously create a
lot of questions so I hope they're
watching this and they're concerned
about this and they're going to
implement something ensure that it
doesn't happen now his argument around
creating this is probably the fact that
if my father were not president maybe I
wouldn't be facing the kind of scrutiny
I'm not saying that's the that that is a
legitimate argument but it's an argument
certainly a credible argument that can
be made I've said many times in the show
I don't pile on people when they're when
they're having problems that and and I'm
not saying that you are judged but I
don't I am because he created the
problem he did well so we disagree there
but he's not a victim Harold but no no
but I just don't pile on people I'm
saying it he has he he had problems in
it remember that weekend we played
twister I thought we were not gonna talk
about that
but I just don't I don't know
okay by the way the Twister weekend does
not disqualify you from the vice
president
just know that we're joking
call call him now seriously hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else